it's early morning on T side and we're
with officers about to Target a
suspected loan shark supported by the
police this is an operation carried out
by What's called the illegal money
lending team
good morning anybody else on the
premises it's estimated more than a
million people could be in debt to
Illegal lenders that numbers trebled in
10 years I am now arresting you both on
suspicion of illegal money lending and
money laundering and as prices of
everyday items saw investigators say the
loan sharks are circling they fear
people who wouldn't normally resort to
an underground lender will do just that
and lose control of their lives we've
seen some horrendous things that people
have been subjected to that we've had
instances in the past where the
Landshark has said to individuals uh pay
me don't feed your children we've we've
also seen illegal lenders that have said
well I'll send men round and you can pay
the debt off through sexual favors so
you know it's just hideous
it takes on average two years for
someone to come forward and admit the
situation they've got into with a loan
shark it means the cases they're dealing
with now are for loans that were taken
out at the start of the pandemic it also
means it will be months before the
impact of the cost of living crisis is
known but the likelihood is that already
people are digging themselves into a
desperate situation increasingly
investigators say loan sharks are
befriending potential victims before
trapping them in a cycle of debt and
intimidation that's what happened to
this woman when she was short of cash a
woman she'd met at the school gate
offered to help her out what started
with 50 pounds soon spiraled the woman
she thought was a friend was a loan
shark who targeted her her words are
spoken by an actor I was stressed over
the repayments I knew I had to pay her
back because I'd seen what she'd done to
other people if they didn't pay her back
I got to the point of wanting to just
end everything I was very suicidal and I
didn't really know who to go to there
were threats on my life there were
threats on my home
and Loan Sharks are also using social
media both to entice victims and then
shame them on group chats to pay up not
surprisingly most borrowers are among
Britain's poorest illegal lenders have
been known to add arbitrary charges
they've also been known to use something
known as double bubble which is a sort
of faux interest rate which is that you
pay back twice what you borrow the
problem with that of course is that if I
borrow 50 pounds and I have to pay a
hundred pounds next week I probably
can't repay it and illegal lenders are
known to double that and double it again
and again and it can often mean that the
interest rate spirals out of control
the illegal money lending team have
prosecuted more than 400 cases writing
off millions in illegal debt the most
common reason people turn to loan sharks
they say is just to cover everyday
expenses and as we know doing that is
getting harder by the date Greg Milam
Sky News Stockton on tease